cette à 16h30 dès la sortie de l'école
que les jumeaux de 10 ans enfants des
victimes sont confrontés à quelque chose
d'inhabituel leur maman de 43 ans
assistante maternelle à domicile n'est
pas là pour les récupérer à la sortie
des classes c'est une voisine venue
chercher ses propres enfants qui prend
alors en charge les jumeaux pour les
raccompagner chez eux elle regarde
et vois quelqu'un dans la maison suite
la limite à la maison avec les enfants
en leur disant nous expliquant ce qui se
passe à quoi à partir de là on s'est dit
bon on va appeler les gendarmes vous
doutiez qui se passait quelque chose de
pas normal
oui c'était pas normal qu'elle ne soit
pas à l'école le temps que les pompiers
arrivent les voisins prennent aussi en
charge la grande soeur des jumeaux âgés
de 12 ans les secouristes déploie
ensuite une échelle pour accéder à la
terrasse et pénètre dans la maison où
ils vont découvrir les corps des deux
parents décédés par arme à feu alors
qu'il informait les gendarmes les
pompiers sont alertés qu'un bébé de 18
mois gardé par l'assistante maternelle
pourraient encore se trouver à
l'intérieur
quelques instants après ils sont
remontés parce que je savais pas qu'il y
avait un petit garçon caché dedans donc
lille on verra une chambre et le bbc l'a
réveillé tranquille
donc quand ils sont sortis et que mémé
dans les bras
hier après midi vers 15 heures des
ouvriers travaillant juste à côté des
lieux du drame ont entendu deux
déflagrations à 30 seconde d'intervalle
ils ont pensé à des pétards le père de
famille était chasseur membres de la
société de chasse locale et compte tenu
des premiers éléments le procureur
donnera cet après midi une conférence de
presse pour assassinats suivis d'un
suicide la mère de famille était venue
le matin en mairie pour signer la
rupture du pacs établi avec son conjoint
elle laisse aussi derrière elle un
quatrième enfants issus d'une première
union